we have folks in the audience who you
know are making works in this time which
you know I would consider a time of
resistance a time of great change and
how have you taken your your perspective
on mortality and grief and and and
created these creative projects and made
these works in the times and 30 years
ago and also now well I guess for me
it's a way to make sense of something
that doesn't necessarily make sense to
me be it the murder of Harvey Milk or my
friends dying of AIDS or the fact that
we all die so it's it's cathartic in a
way to be able to dive deep into a
subject and try and make sense of it in
a way that you can present your
experience or someone other someone
else's experience of that issue I think
that's the most simple reductionistic
explanation I can give you know it's
it's the thing that we all experience in
these these experiences are the most
universal experiences and why we choose
to approach what feel like dark and
forbidding subjects I can't tell you but
I think the the thing that that we
really grasp onto when we're making the
films is that this is something that
everybody will be able to relate to in
some way or understand totally agree
with both you guys it's I think we're
all in this together right and I mean
like today we're all immigrants I bet
there's not a single person here who his
family didn't immigrate here
we are all connected whether we like it
or not we're all connected and films
like this remind you that we're all
connected and I think it's important
especially in this era when it just
seems to be blowing apart
I mean remember the 60s we did it with
the thing I could remember thinking that
can never be very worse than Nixon and
now he looks like me he started the EPA
for chrissake he's like looks like a
lefty so I think these things are useful
in so far as they remind people that
there is a connection which again
getting back to the quilt
I mean quilts are connected they're all
sewn together you know and so it's sort
of comes full circle here when I came
out to Hollywood I was a kid I was a
callow kid and all I was interested in
at the time was sex drugs and
rock'n'roll and wanting to get my name
in the paper I wanted to get out of the
best parties and then when the AIDS
crisis hit and my doctor said to me
thought I had AIDS and and what I really
had was a lactose intolerance that
Shirley MacLaine figured out and I
remember saying to myself I get a second
chance if God gives me a second chance
you know [ __ ] Barbra Streisand [ __ ] the
parties I don't give a [ __ ] about
anything else all I care about now is
the work and out of that came come
thread celluloid closet paragraph 175
Project Angel Food you know all my great
movie tape you know call me by her name
you know and that's the most important
thing is the work because that's what
changes the social structure
[Applause]